how can you be ready for what's ahead
data science has gone from hype to
reality what was once the realm of
scientists and engineers has become
central to healthcare government finance
advertising even education
if you're a leader or a decision maker
or you're just looking to make sense of
data science
this is your place to start
it's not a programming course instead
it's meant to give you the tools you
need for a world that will never stop
giving you more information
featuring real world case studies and
interviews with industry experts
digging deep into examples from
healthcare privacy and more
we'll show you what worked hey i saw
what you guys did in san francisco let's
do it in somerville too inequities in
the health and criminal justice system
police brutality issues issues around
colvin these are all problems that big
data can affect
we'll show you what didn't work
unfortunately i think as an institution
we got out ahead of ourselves if
somebody takes a data set that's
supposed to be anonymous and they
re-identify the people in it all kinds
of harms can happen this technology was
not just science fiction it was becoming
science reality and you'll find out why
the information is at your fingertips
are you data science ready
[Music]
you